- Well, the hour is almost up,
but let's get to one last story
that might make you smile.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
For over a century, people
across Latin America
have enjoyed the game Loteria.
It's basically a version of Bingo
in which each square is
represented by an image.
Not long ago, a Los
Angeles man was looking
at the old set that he had
played as a kid in Guatemala
and he realized that those images
really didn't represent the
younger generation of Latinos.
So, he decided to invest his life savings
into making a modern set.
It's become a huge hit and
something we want to celebrate
this Hispanic Heritage Month.
Everybody, let's welcome the creator
of Millennial Loteria, Mike.
What's up, Mike?
- Hola, Kelly. Hi, everyone.
- Hola. So, okay, great to meet you.
Can you explain the game a little more
and how you updated it?
- Yeah, so the great thing about Loteria,
it is not just a game,
it is a tradition, like you say,
that was, has been played
for countless generations.
And one of the things that I
saw is that, as Millennials,
we grew up playing this
game with, like, our family,
our abuelas.
But as time went on, we kind
of put down the Loteria set
and started picking up our cell phones
and our video games and,
you know, watching TV
and kind of not playing that game anymore.
And so, I'm a firm believer that Loteria
doesn't belong in, like, a
Latin American history museum.
It belongs in your living room.
So, I decided that I wanted to update it
to reflect modern Latino
Millennials nowadays.
So, for instance, the old Loteria
it had a a picture of la
dama, which is the lady.
And so, I decided I wanted to update that
to make sure that Millennials
felt more represented.
So, it's 2022.
She's no longer just la
dama, she's now la feminist.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so, I started putting
these updates online,
and it went viral.
So, it was very exciting
for me to see, you know,
people reacting to me updating
a card to be el hipster,
el global warming, la selfie,
la student debt, el pride.
- La student debt. This is awesome.
So, why do you think
that this is resonating
with younger people, and
how do older Latinos react
to the modern version?
It's so funny.
- Well, thank you.
I mean, you know, we've sold
over half a million sets to date.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- So I'm celebrating
that younger generations
have felt really, you know,
represented in this game.
And it's also a fun game
for older people, too.
I mean, there's always gonna
be Boomers who are like,
Millennials are ruining everything again,
Millennials ruining Loteria,
but I think it's also a fun game
to bring generations together
and to show how, you know,
there's things that unite us.
At the end of the day,
regardless of what the
images of the cards are,
Loteria is a game that
brings people together,
that creates fond memories with people.
And I'm really passionate about having
not only this game
celebrated around the world,
but having other cultures embrace, too,
how fun it is to play this game.
- Absolutely. I'm down.
I love game night, and
that is awesome and funny.
You did a great job with
your life savings, brother.
Thank you so much, Mike.
I'm liking your post right now.
(bell dings)
- [Mike] Thanks a lot.
- And that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, sir,
making a difference for
their culture and community.
So, they'll be writing
you a check for $1000.
How's that sound?
- Wow! Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you so much, Kelly.
That's amazing. I'm super excited.